have video footage for you it shows the
protesters who are the ukrainian
national youth sailing team boarding a
small dinghy or a tender to try and
prevent the 430 million pounds super
yacht from docking at the aegean sea
resort
of bodrum
uh well the sailing teams coach pavlov
donats um joins me now um good afternoon
to you thank you for joining us here on
sky news after your um exploits earlier
on today
hello hello everyone glory to recreating
um
perhaps you can start by telling us you
and your team are in turkey you were
there for as part of a regatta
how did you come to find out that this
super yacht uh was there and how did you
find out it belonged to roman abramovich
what led you um to protest today
okay
yep right now we are with the sailors
uh we keep moving with our basic plan
and we are in a boardroom
we are
preparing for the boardroom
international regatta which will start
it from first of april
till the 6th of april and right now we
have trainings here
and we've got a call from our friend
albert kabakov he's
a director of
black sea odessa yacht club
he's got some information that
the
yacht of
russian
russian
oligarch is going to
to go to the boardroom and we just
decided with all team to make something
important to make something useful for
our our country for our people and we
just we just took the flex and go go
inside
pavlo we understand why you did it as
you said you wanted to to make a protest
to make a stand you're making headlines
around the world but i'm just looking at
the size of your vessel compared to this
super yacht that looks very dangerous
talk to me about how you and your team
navigated this protest on the water
yeah everybody should know that
i'm a professional coach and the sailors
are professionals and every movement
every action from our side it was
totally safety
and um
we just made um
we just made safety actions but
as we see now
we will get our goal to
to
let all people from all over the world
to know that ukrainian
and ukrainian people and the country
deserves
uh to be
um
freedom to have freedom and uh
and um
and have a peace in ukraine
um it's important to point out it was a
peaceful protest describe to us what you
did and did anyone from on board that
boat come out to talk to you do you know
if roman abramovich was on board who who
came out to speak to you
[Music]
we just got any any words from from the
boat uh we've got some um some words
from the land from the staff
of
turkish port they said that
guys
it's not it's not safety please go away
but we talked that to them that it is a
boat of
of a man who is somehow connected with
the russian government
which started the war on our land in
ukraine and nobody nobody's
speak
with us from from the boat
but we saw some people there
um pavlov where your voices have been
heard not just by the crew onboard that
super yacht but as i said
around the world this is making
headlines um can i ask you what the
situation is like for your friends and
family at home in ukraine obviously
you're in turkey at this regatta for you
and your team it's
it's as much as it can be business as
usual but what's happening back at home
for your family pablo
yeah it is difficult it is really
difficult situation for us because right
now
we have sailors
and their parents are they in ukraine
somebody in kiev
personally my parents in odessa
and
some parrots from odessa region
and we realize
the true news from them
and it is
it is really sad to
realize that it is
totally um military horror in ukraine
so we just want to support
somehow
for all our parents relatives friends
and
everybody should know that ukrainian
people are together
and all over the world
well pavlo you
took a peaceful protest to that super
yacht the size of your boat it was david
and goliath in comparison and i think
you know that
that analogy is very clear for the war
as a whole and just as a as a final
point
what would your message be what was the
message you were trying to get um by
approaching that boat this peaceful
protest what would your message be to to
people watching today
yeah we just we just realized and
our opinion and opinion of our team
it is that
all all the countries and all the
nations should should make
some actions to stop the war
because
this war is not only about ukraine uh i
think it is
it is about
all europe and all the world
and
i think we should do some actions to
to don't let
any
russian people who somehow connected
with the
russian government and
somehow
connected with the war on our land
they should not
feel comfortable
uh
in other city
of turkey of europe and
everywhere
and pavlo what has been your experience
because obviously you compete in
international events you are meeting
sailors from other countries around the
world what are the international
community
saying to you about what's happening in
your country
yeah we have a lot of experience by the
way we left ukraine
before the war just started we left
ukraine on 23rd of january
to have
to participate in
in couple regattas in spain
and
we have a lot of supportness you know
from from
all over the europe especially from
sailing federations clubs and uh because
because our team have
some names some results and we know each
other in europe so we we have a great
great supportness from all our friends
all over europe and turkey and we are
really thankful
for this
because it is it is very important for
the kids to realize that they are not
alone right now in in this terrible
situation
uh well pavlo we're just showing viewers
now um footage that you filmed from on
board that tender as you approach that
super yacht that we believe um or we
understand
belongs to the russian oligarch uh
romibravovich one of the number of
oligarchs sanctioned by the uk and
taking that peaceful protest
up to that boat to get your message not
just to them but as i've said and to
people watching around the globe we wish
you
and your fellow team members well the
ukrainian national youth sailing team
currently about to compete in a regatta
in bodrum in turkey